concours de fin d'année au conservatoire
national d'art dramatique examen
redoutable qui jauge un candidat sur
tous les plans de l'expression
artistique et corporelle en confrontant
son degré de maturité aux grands auteurs
du répertoire classique et moderne
dans la tente des résultats professeur
comédiens chevronnés et élèves font
leurs pronostics
cette année pour les premiers prix de
comédie le verdict du jury rejoindra
celui du public
voulez vous serez messieurs francis m
[Applaudissements]
si l'on attendait andré dussolier en
craignent en revanche pour le non
conformisme ou de francis paiera forte
éloignée de la tradition pisé ans élu il
y en a rien été ce qui marque une très
nette évolution
oui madame actuellement une grande brune
piquante et il fut il n'y a pas moyen
monsieur refuse tout gelé tromperait mme
digitimes
je ne puis les aimer mon coeur est parti
j'ai voulu crier messieurs personnes à
la fin pourtant il revint lui avec 1 ére
gars et je jetais dans une voiture et
nous retourne à ma la maison j'ai dû
faire et que ça se fasse en ligue 1 je
lai il paraît que vous êtes un garçon
pour une diplôme universitaire cet exode
c'était hier à bourg et sur l'espagne
enfin j'ai des diplômes universitaires
et que j'ai de licence et une maîtrise
de lettres modernes pour quelles raisons
avez vous choisi le théâtre alors que
l'enseignement s'ouvrait devant parce
que j'ai toujours
lire des théâtres et j'ai eu envie de
cet enseignement est que j'ai surtout
envie de faire des lettres et c'est pour
ça que j'ai fait des études de lettres
mais j'ai toujours fait du théâtre et
devient le théâtre que je s'appelle
chéri
[Musique]